well you know I was a regulator in the
nuclear arena and you know nuclear
science and technology nuclear energy is
an area that people tend to feel as
strongly about is some social issues so
much so that maybe it is one when you're
in that arena and you know it is an
important technology and it has a role
in this energy future we're talking
about but it is a very sensitive
technology that has to be handle weld in
design in construction and especially in
operation and it has a very
sophisticated regulatory infrastructure
that it really needs to accompany but
the real message is when you're thinking
about the use of nuclear power then risk
has two components its probability of
something untoward happening and its
consequence and they are certain arenas
where the consequence is so high that
even if one thinks the probability is
small then one has to take mitigating
steps and so that's what I would say an
answer to your question about climate
change because whether we think the
probabilities are high that it is
already upon us or will be within a
short time when we think consequence
then it says that maybe we mitigate and
whether we think that climate changes
are due to some fundamental long period
periodicity natural evolution that
depends on other things if there is any
exacerbating effect that we have on top
of that and we think we can lessen that
exacerbating effect or if you think we
really drive see what we see in either
of those cases because of consequence we
should do something about
but even if we don't believe it at all
just as you mentioned the question of
two billion people that really don't
even have access to real energy where
people's are still living in poverty and
everybody wants to rise and developing
countries wish to rise then just the
global competition for what in the end
is always a limited resource says we
ought to be smarter about how we use it
you know what effect it has and so
that's what always links these two
things energy security and climate
change and so what you really do in the
one impacts and can impact in a positive
way what happens in the other so if you
believe in climate change and therefore
we should go to alternative renewable
energy sources or you believe in energy
quote-unquote independence and I never
talked about that I always say energy
security then maybe you go to renewables
as well and so that's where I think we
all need to try to come together a
little bit more
I do think they can be effective it is
not easy but but there are known
compounds that can can capture co2 from
flue gas and there are techniques for
pumping co2 into you know storage
reservoirs but they are still our
studies that need to be done and
understood in terms of how much of an
engineered reservoir do we need that is
what is the role of engineered systems
as opposed to natural reservoirs and if
we think we want to use natural
reservoirs then we have to understand
things like porosity escape paths how
long can the carbon or the co2 be
sequestered and are there other things
that we can use that involve natural
vegetation or things that are that bio
mimic natural vegetation that can
actually bind the co2 or even turn it
into more elemental forms of carbon so
so the answer is yes I think it is a
solvable problem is it a challenge
absolutely but you know the deal we owe
the Department of Energy already is
starting to do a number of projects and
demonstration projects and interestingly
enough a number of energy companies as
well are starting to look at these
things and to begin to do things to
sequester carbon and and and the irony
is the kind of infrastructure that we
use to extract gas and to get oil is the
same infrastructure that we can use to
sequester carbon